you're a vegan that's a recent
development yes very recent how did that
happen um first of one very loud vegan
uh yeah it's unusual he sounded like he
had a lot of wind usually vegans are
very weak from lack of paper usually
vegans oh oh he's asleep right now he's
right back to sleep he woke up heard
vegan him he's dreaming of walnuts
my my my wife loves to rescue the
animals and she rescued these two
pot-bellied pigs and they live in our
backyard what this is true okay
yeah snorting tynin amy and they we
built them a little piggy door and they
come in at night and they sleep on their
little piggy beds I think we have a
picture here of your pot-bellied pig
sleep oh yeah they're fantastic they
show in in the morning once I was up
they hadn't gotten up yet they like to
sleep in and I was microwaving some of
that Trader Joe's bacon and chomping on
it looking at these adorable little pigs
you know she makes it she puts them
through these little tricks they play a
little miniature piano for treats they
get little animal crackers right and it
sounds like they're in hell so it just
was heartbreaking to sit there looking
at their Buer eating bacon while you
were looking at them it was it was
McCobb and terrifying and so i went
vegan but unfortunately now i'm that
annoying vegan friend that you go to the
restaurant like to have any vegan
options you know I want vegan what does
that have cheese in it you knows I'm
that guy you want on Thanksgiving did
you have a Tofurky I had a I had a I
just had an entire celery plant
and beach that's uh yeah
[Applause]
you